jeff when did you first get involved in
cg um when i was in college i i was a
math major and one of the requirements
was to take a computer course and i ran
into this course in computer generated
music music
and since i
had inherited a filmmaking background
from my brother randall as a filmmaker
um i sort of became interested in using
computers creatively and
as a drummer you know i was toying
around with you know 132nd notes and on
the computer and being able to do all
kinds of different rhythmic uh
structures
and uh at one at one point i was up in
syracuse working uh for ibm on a special
studies
program and i happened to live above a
professor
there who was making
very simple wireframe images with
computers and
and that's when i remember the light
bulb above my head was almost visible uh
that
using uh computers creatively to make
images and films was something i was
going to be extremely interested in
so in the early 70s i had started
experimenting with video coming out of a
traditional art background
and i quickly realized that
the art world at least just existed then
was not really hip to what was going on
in that kind of world there was it was a
video world
uh but it was coming out of a conceptual
art tradition
but there was another kind of thing
going on with imagery which i associated
with music
so at that time the people i was working
with were into creating synthesized
music
and images that worked together
but what i quickly figured out was that
we were working kind of with a special
effects machine that if you really
wanted control of what was going on you
needed to control every dot
on the screen and at that time there was
no way to do that and that's when i
discovered that at xerox park exactly
such a device had been designed by a
fellow named dick shaup
roughly 1973 1974 and so at the
beginning of 1975 i went down there got
a look at a system they had called super
paint
it blew my mind it was my aha moment
and i went well this is the future of
everything this is where it's all going
to go so that's where i first saw it
actually i first got into computers way
back in
1973 1974
when i was studying
at rhode island school design and i saw
a computer animated film it was actually
a stereo film
by
michael knoll and it was presented by
two professors at brown who are doing
some of the earliest work in computer
animation
so
i had decided that's what i want to do i
like alice davis i also was dismayed to
find i couldn't actually be an animator
in the industry because women weren't
allowed to be at that time
so i thought
two things i thought
the computer is is really going to be
important for society and as an artist
i'd like to be involved in the invention
of it and the creative use of it
but i also thought being an animator
that
the computer could make things easier
for me or could make it so that i could
do my own independent work
and um so these were my inspirations one
of my friends uh said come with me and i
jumped in her car and i went to rhode
island school of design
for a summer program and i saw um thomas
banshoff who was at brown university and
he was showing
a um
he was showing four-dimensional math
animated using computer animation but it
was pretty much just
um
a white white wire frame on a black
background but it was like absolutely
astonishing to see um like hypercubes
and like
uh like
surfaces that were turning inside out um
animated i'd never seen that before and
i
i realized this is what i had to do so i
went back to boston university where
there was a a computer graphics
like for um graduate program i intended
to get into that
but then then suddenly made a sharp turn
and decided that i would need an art
background before
before getting into computer graphics
because i knew it was headed in a
creative direction even though it was
sort of
operated by programmers
up to that point
you